who would win in a duel who's the better
teacher and who had the better story
today we'll put some of the classic
Wizarding World professors from the
Harry Potter series up against some of
our new favorites from Hogwarts Legacy
and for a battle this epic I certainly
could not do it on my own so it's why I
asked you the community as well as a few
Harry Potter Creator friends to help me
out first up it's Minerva McGonagall vs
Matilda Weasley there are quite a few
similarities between these two starting
with the fact that they're both
gryffindors both Deputy head Mistresses
and both have the respect of their
students and colleagues alike they're
also incredibly talented witches that
began their careers working for the
ministry of magic Weasley is a curse
breaker and McGonagall in a position
with the department for Magical law
enforcement McGonagall is certainly a
bit more Stern whereas Weasley comes
across as having a more warm demeanor
but which one of these characters would
win in a head-to-head duel it was a
landslide victory in our community Poll
for Minerva McGonagall as she took 91
percent of the vote with more than 17
000 votes cast our panel of creators
also agreed with 80 percent giving the
nod to McGonagall in a duel Benjamin
snow was particularly confident in
mcgonagall's abilities overall saying I
think McGonagall would slay them all if
she wanted to as for me it's hard to
disagree with these results McGonagall
held her own on more than one occasion
throughout the original Seven book
series and who can forget her epic
battle with Severus Snape Weasley was
certainly more than capable in our
classes with her and during this epic
battle at the end of the game but we
just have so much more to go on with
McGonagall that it's hard not to give
her the nod here how about who's the
better teacher as great as they both are
this one was even more of a landslide
victory for McGonagall with her taking
90 of the vote from our creator panel
honestly I think this one would be
pretty even for me and most likely
depend on the personality of the student
I can see some learning better under
Weasley's more gentle approach but
Others May Thrive under mcgonagall's
no-nonsense approach who has the better
story another victory for McGonagall as
she again took 90 percent of the panel
vote and by the way guys there's even
more to mcgonagall's backstory than we
got in the original seven books as
wizard PhD said in the survey if you
don't Know mcgonagall's full backstory
go get some tissues and search for it
now and so for the first Professor
battle it's one vote for the OG
professors with Minerva McGonagall
coming out on top up next we have our
charms professors philius Flitwick
versus Abraham Ronan Flitwick may not be
as beloved as some of the original
professors like McGonagall but there's
no doubt the head of Ravenclaw was an
incredibly talented Wizard and excellent
charms Professor during Harry's years at
Hogwarts he was also part Goblin as well
as a former dueling Champion Ronan on
the other hand is our enthusiastic
charms professor in Hogwarts Legacy and
he certainly goes against many of the
traditional Slytherin stereotypes his
Stern upbringing from his father
ultimately led to Ronan developing a
love for games of all kinds during his
time at Hogwarts as Professor he loved
to incorporate gameplay into his lessons
leading him to being a favorite among
Hogwarts students during the late 1800s
our dueling poll was closer here but
Flitwick took the victory with 66
percent saying he would win and and
considering his status as a former
dueling champion this one is probably an
accurate result again our creator panel
agrees with the community here with 8
out of 10 responding saying Flitwick
would win the duel as far as who's the
better teacher we get our first clear
win for a Hogwarts Legacy Professor with
70 of our panel going with Ronan over
Flitwick Ronan also came out on top when
I asked who has the better story with 8
out of 10 siding with the Hogwarts
Legacy professor and I have to say I
agree with both the panel and the
community yet again here I think Ronan
could hold his own in a duel but
probably wouldn't stand much of a chance
against Flitwick considering his
experience in dueling as for teaching I
really enjoyed ronan's style in Hogwarts
Legacy and of course with it being a
video game his love for gameplay and
introducing us to the Summoners Court
minigame has to play a big factor here
does have an interesting backstory but I
think you could make a pretty good
argument that flitwicks is more
interesting but it's also fair to say we
don't really get much of that backstory
in the books overall looks like Ronan
will take this round over Flitwick now
we head to the dungeons to decide which
potion Master will come out on top with
Severus Snape versus ESOP sharp again we
have some similarities here with both
being of how Slytherin and similar
brooding demeanors sharp worked as an
aura for the ministry and suffered an
injury to his leg on the very same
assignment that actually took the life
of his partner not wanting to be stuck
at a desk for the rest of his career
sharp opted for the potion's job at
Hogwarts instead as for Snape he remains
one of the most iconic characters from
the original series from his love for
Lily and being bullied at the hands of
the Marauders to his decision to become
a Death Eater and serve Lord Voldemort
to ultimately turning spy for Dumbledore
Snape is one of the most fascinating
characters from the entire series he was
also an incredibly powerful wizard with
many slotting him a notch just below
Dumbledore and Voldemort and let's not
forget as last Marauder points out Snape
even created his own spells with some of
them being really powerful dark magic
even with sharp being a former Aura and
even if we have this hypothetical duel
before his injury it's hard to see him
best in Severus Snape and no surprise
here you guys agreed with with more than
sixteen thousand votes and ninety one
percent of you saying Snape would win
the duel our creator panel was almost
identical with 9 out of 10 siding with
Snape as far as who's the better teacher
I have to give that one to Sharp and
ninety percent of the Creator panel
agreed even though Snape definitely knew
his subject matter his abrasive teaching
style at times even veered into abusive
especially for Harry and his friends and
while no one is gonna label sharp as
gregarious his rigid structure and
no-nonsense attitude seemed to come more
from a place of wanting to see students
try their best and not simply settle for
getting by who has the better story
though uh yeah sorry sharp but this one
was our first unanimous poll result with
100 of the panel saying Snape had the
better story to be fair sharp could have
a fascinating story that we just don't
know yet but Snape's character Arc
throughout the entire books is really
really tough to beat so sharp takes one
of the three questions here but Snape is
going to come out on top overall which
gives the Potter professors a 2-1 lead
next if I had to name the one Hogwarts
Legacy Professor that's gotten the most
love from fans I think it would have to
be our herbology professor Mirabelle
garlic but does she have what it takes
to knock off Pomona Sprout garlic is a
muggle-born Hufflepuff with an
incredibly cheerful and welcoming
attitude she received a Hogwarts
herbology award during her seventh year
Miranda Lauren had some really
passionate words for garlic here garlic
is goated team garlic yeah Sprout is
also a Hufflepuff though and she
attended Hogwarts during some of the
same years as McGonagall with them
overlapping by two years she would often
bring interesting plants from the
greenhouses to decorate the Hufflepuff
common room but for one of the original
Potter professors we really don't have
that many details and backstory from
Sprout she does play a fairly prominent
role in the Harry Potter Hogwarts
mystery mobile game as for a duel though
this one is probably even more guesswork
than the others we never see garlic in
battle during the video game and while
we see a few examples of sprout joining
the fight of the books she's often using
magical plants rather than her wand both
the community and the creators agreed
here they gave the nod to Professor
garlic in a duel she was received 75
percent of the community votes and 80
percent from the panel who's the better
teacher another big win for garlic at 90
percent of the panel vote here and it
was actually another 90 in favor of
garlic on who had the better story I can
see why this one was a bit harder given
that we know so little about Sprout's
backstory and also very little about how
these two would fare in a duel truth be
told they would probably seek to avoid a
duel in any way possible especially if
it was a duel against one another on the
story side it's probably more about
potential with both of these characters
we get a little bit on garlic in her
friendship with sirona Ryan through
letters we also know she's still waiting
for the right witch to come along when
it comes to our romantic partner Sprout
as I mentioned features prominently in
Hogwarts mystery but it's mostly just
her working as the herbology professor
and not much when it comes to
introducing new backstory for her
overall I have to side with the panel
here and give this one to Professor
garlic and would you look at that
heading into the final round we have two
wins for the Potter professors and two
wins for the Hogwarts Legacy professors
and honestly this last one though is by
far the toughest best one to tackle the
fact that it is even this close I think
is a testament to the wonderful job
Avalanche did with the professors in
Hogwarts Legacy nightly nerd did a good
job summing this up here the professors
from both the books and game were
special in their own way I wish we got
to know all of them better especially
the professors from the game as it's a
living world rather than a narrative
series that has no room to change Side
characters in gaming have the special
opportunity to be explored in depth
expecto go also echoed this sentiment
saying the Hogwarts Legacy professors
didn't get enough time to show their
teaching skills great backstories though
so that made it hard to figure out who
would win in a duel or who was the
better teacher but that being said guys
we do need to Crown a winner here so to
decide it all we turn to defense against
the dark arts with Dina heckett versus
Remus Lupine Professor Lupine a
Gryffindor played a vital role in the
original series when he was introduced
to US during Harry's third year at
Hogwarts we learned of his friendship
with Harry's Father James and he taught
Harry about a variety of dark magical
creatures perhaps most importantly
though he taught Harry the Patronus
charm which he would need at a few key
moments throughout the story Dinah
heckett is of house Ravenclaw and has
what I think is the most fascinating
backstory in all of Hogwarts Legacy at
least when it comes to the professors
she introduces us to Dueling encourages
us to join the cross once dueling club
and we also learned that she worked for
the ministry of magic as an unspeakable
before coming to teach at Hogwarts as a
student she was voted head girl and
excelled in her studies and for the
first time throughout this entire battle
our community and the Creator panel
disagreed on who would win the duel you
guys the community voted 68 in favor of
Professor Lupine our creator panel
however it was close but we saw a 70 30
split in favor of Professor heckett so I
guess that leaves me to break the tie
here and guys as much as I love Lupine
as a character and he's certainly a
strong wizard I have to go with heckett
in a straight up duel okay so here's my
reasoning here unfortunately due to
Lupine being bitten by a werewolf he
likely did not have the same
opportunities as heckett espec after
graduating from Hogwarts she also
introduces our character to Dueling in
Hogwarts Legacy and we see her playing a
big role in the final battle of the game
Lupine certainly showed he was more than
capable in battle throughout the series
but taking all of these factors into
account I'm siding with heckett by an
Ever So slight margin the next question
may surprise you a bit as our creator
panel came out strongly in favor of
Lupine on who's the better teacher
question Lupine received 90 of the votes
here so with that it's all tied up going
into the final question and all that's
left who had the better story now I
already said that Professor Hackett had
what I think was the best backstory of
the Hogwarts Legacy professors if you
missed this line of dialogue in the game
it only happens when you return to her
classroom and have additional
conversations with her you'll learn
she's actually much younger than she
appears she went to school with
Professor black during her time at the
ministry though she was wounded by time
itself it seems highly likely that she
studied the very same time room we see
all those years later when Harry and his
friends battled Death Eaters in the
department of mysteries that being said
though lupine's story from Marauder to
werewolf to professor and ultimately to
husband and father were amazing and
again to be fair heckett's story has the
potential to rival this but we just have
so much more already on Lupine purple
Witcher said heckett's desire for Action
means she wins The Duel Lupine didn't do
that much teaching but his animagus
story is fascinating overall the Creator
panel would agree 90 of the votes went
to Remus Lupine which means by an ever
so slim margin the pot of professors
just barely come out on top over the
Hogwarts Legacy professors the
professors aren't the only ones with
great stories in Hogwarts Legacy though
no character has been discussed more
than our Slytherin companion Sebastian
sallow I have a full breakdown of seb's
complete storyline and the emotional
impact of that Journey already live on
my channel I'll link it on the right
side of the screen now as always thank
you guys so much for watching and thanks
to the creators in the community for
participating I'll talk to you again
soon